[Applause]
what do you think about the nash thing
i think it's it's a great hire well what
did you think about like the white
privilege
it's it's it was a dump mark like it's a
dumb argument and here's why
yeah because white privilege will break
down the argument for anybody who's
listening
so steve nash is uh a player who
basically was the hall of famer and won
the mvp twice
um and since he's retired he's had like
little
kind of side assistant coach jobs but
nothing major
he got the head coaching job in brooklyn
and
uh it's a job that a lot of people
obviously wanted because you have kyrie
irving you have kevin durant it's in
brooklyn
brand new facility all those things and
there are people who got mad
and said this is a another example of
white privilege
white guy comes in and he gets this
coveted job and all that
and i said it's a dumb argument because
racial kind of uh disparity in hiring
practices is real that is a real thing
that happens
not only in this league but all over
every business
in this country right it's a real thing
having said that you picked the worst
example of something
that is not that to apply this thing
which only does one thing
it bolsters the argument of actual
racist people
saying see like no matter what happens
you complain
right exactly call everything racist
right you call everything racist
and so the reason is obviously unique
because steve nash is the next player
he's a two-time embassy
it's not unique though it's not
unprecedented jason kidd went straight
from playing
the next year head coaching he barely
retired playing it was like it was one
he got the job so by the way i got to
put in my retirement business
yeah right yeah so this is what i said
it's not white privilege it's superstar
privilege
our league is built on these great
superstars
making it interesting many people tune
in everyone from wilt to magic and bird
and jordan and lebron
that's our legacy right these guys built
it so that
all of us whether you're a media person
whether you're a minimum guy
whether you're a gm we're all making
more money and there are more of these
jobs for us
as a result there's a uh at the comedy
club sometimes there'll be like
journeyman comics complaining
that like a really famous comic bumps
them right
you know like a chris rock or somebody
will even come down or like maybe even
somebody
much less than chris rock but still
famous enough will like bump their spot
lineup and these comics will a lot of
times i complain i can't believe
aziz is bumping me or something like
that and
i always looked at that i was like you
idiot
they them performing here is the reason
why we're all
well we have a job that's why we could
that's why they can do three or four
shows
this is the pr this is going to be in
the post tomorrow it's going to be new
york times
it's the reason these shows are going to
be sold out why people show up maybe as
eas will drop in exactly
exactly they're hoping this is going to
happen and then you just get me
and then you just get me what do you
mean how's the time they don't notice
yeah i know aziz is great i never got
angrier
i never noticed his eyes
uh but no that's that's exactly it they
raise the tides
that we all we all win right yeah the
thank you we give them is
maybe sometimes you don't have to wait
in line right yes so
you don't have to do that i was a video
coordinator and then i was a player
no you don't have to do that they talk
about spoil stress oh good man no i
but like this is fine i'm talking about
myself i had to do this [ __ ]
yeah but like there was never a moment
in my life where i thought look at this
[ __ ] right here like
he gets to skip no that's what he gets
you got a couple mvps yes
yes exactly like five four
and white and i got the mvp twice
coach whoever [ __ ] fisher cut in line
man like yeah
that is the most offensive one yeah doc
rivers cut in line
like i mean like i say super star but
like it's great
rivers overrated bro can we really have
this conversation
blown a 3-1 lead three times no his
team's the pistons back and like
remember when tracy mcgrady
was like i'm so happy to finally be out
of the first round he's up 3-1 on the
pistons i think
yeah he was with the magic dog coaching
magics i'm so happy to be out of the
first round
weight lifted off my shoulders then they
lose three straight lose a series
clippers against houston are up big in
the closeout game
3-1 or 3-2 at the time i know they had a
3-1 lead they lose the series and then
these clippers
that's right yeah wow so is doc
overrated he's over and underrated it's
kind of weird
okay yeah like i think doc definitely
does a great job of building the
mystique around him
yeah doc is really smart in the press
conferences he does the thing where like
you ask a question and like
that's a very that's a great question
and like media people like that they
feel good
and so like they write nice [ __ ] about
that and i don't think it's like on
purpose i think it's just someone who
makes you feel good
you're not gonna throw everything at him
so he does that very well
i think at the same time doc is like
he's a really good coach like we saw
that clipper team last year
nobody they traded everybody and
everyone's like oh they're tanking they
end up making the playoffs because doc
coached his ass off
he's really good at coaching and
normally he's really good at getting
guys to buy in
i think this year was a tough year for
him and it's up here for them
you could tell those guys look like
that's what i said they look like five
guys who just met
like yeah i mean like beverly and uh and
lou didn't even want to be there
they didn't want to be there they said
it publicly you don't got to like mince
your words here yeah they said it
publicly they tried to leave yeah
i don't like this intentional foul i
mean i want you to
for real you can't play a game seven
with those guys
i don't want lou williams patrick
beverly this year
lou i [ __ ] love patrick beverly is a
nut but lou i [ __ ] love but lou
i'm gonna go to the strip club and get
some chicken wings lou i don't want him
i don't want him on my team for game
seven this year but it's it's not you
know it's weird because
you know everyone like the mike malone
the coach of nuggets like oh you guys
didn't believe in us
you went down 3-1 though yeah like like
yes it's great to come back from
3-1 down right it's a great feat but we
have to start with
you put yourself in a position to be
down that much
right it would be like if i had a
million dollars yeah and then i blew 999
999 dollars right and then with that
last dollar
like a way to come back i came up with a
million and one no i didn't believe in
you
yeah you blew a million you gave me
every reason not to give me every reason
not to believe in you yeah
like it wasn't you didn't start broke
and then like work your way through this
you made yourself broke
and then you built it but you gotta do
nobody believes in us of course of
course yeah it's a motivation every
edge at that level you could get you
need but so having said it's weird that
doc would just let that fall apart like
you gotta put that
on a coach did you see that [ __ ] in game
six when he's like begging them
to play i'm like yo i've never seen this
[ __ ] in a
for a vet team in the playoffs i've
never seen no [ __ ] like so here's the
thing we were talking about the other
day which is like
kawhi has had this huge privilege
of playing for solid organizations his
entire career
and he's never been in a place where he
actually had to step up
and motivate like kawhi just gets to
show up
do the job go home because everything
else is handled for him right the player
relations are handled right
who gets the ball is handled anybody
doesn't hit bad if somebody comes out
slaps him on the wrist and then he goes
to the clippers and
the clippers needed the alpha dog to
start smacking people in the [ __ ]
mouth
they need they needed they needed
someone and cause i sat there and
mumbled like a [ __ ]
autistic kid on the bench they needed a
kobe or jordan no i mean they needed a
calorie
they don't they need a coffee or jordan
they just needed somebody
who's going to stand they needed david
west like just a dude who stands up and
says they need udonis
yeah yeah has them yeah yep going udon
i'm going i'm
his tribal name yeah no but you know
what it's like
it would be like if you showed up here
walked in sat down are we recording
record and then you got up and left
exactly and then you want to do every
week but the reality is
there's a lot more [ __ ] to it you got
that point out mark that
mark that and we're going to replay that
right back
okay there's a lot more [ __ ] to it than
just showing up and doing quote unquote
the job is bigger than the job
description but he hasn't had to do
those other things
no there's no ease with the situation i
would say the clippers are a good
organization first of all i don't want
to
they're not the same clippers as they
were before right right no they're so
different
they're so different i mean just ever
since steve ballmer bought the team it's
been nothing but winning
yeah it's so different it's it's a lot
more winning than it was under
the other yeah right they have more
winning under steve ballmer in like
playoffs and disappoint everybody
they've been doing they didn't even used
to get to the playoffs he's a weird
looking guy isn't he bummer yeah
oh yeah he looks like a [ __ ] beluga
whale
have you ever seen one of those beluga
whales in like this
what are they called here the water like
an aquarium yeah
just that bald head stupid face
you know what i mean does he pay you
what's going on bummer yeah yeah
i wish he would man he got money bro
he's got more money
more money than the next 15 nba owners
[Applause]
combined
you